tell me a bit more about Becky what was
Becky like she was just perfect
feisty funny like good situation I have
anything bad she'd always make you laugh
as well
how have you tried to get through the
last nine months what's it been like The
Omen how have you managed to deal with
it I'm just trying to doing everything
for her really anything left done on me
my mom's done is just being probably
strictly for her I still don't really
seem well just nine months of just Li
haven't seen us really you grew up with
Nathan yeah what's your reaction to the
prison sentences that they've got life
with him but minimum 33 years 17 years
for Shawna still not enough for him or
her
do you think he should ever be released
from prison no why not because it
wouldn't be safe right I think teenagers
or anyone they're b61 recurso and
they're still be looking for teenagers
because it's gone in that tell me a
little bit more about Becky and Nathan
what was their relationship like did you
ever have any suspicions no when I would
wait when I was living her when I'd go
there like from my mum's it would just
be like brother and sister like playing
like playfully in our joking about or
someone but I never knew like the way he
was thinking stuff in his head obviously
obviously them like joking about and it
was like a love-hate relationship type
thing but I never o'clock Taunton to
what was going on what do you when you
think about him now how do you see him
when you think about growing on with him
animal just kooky animal but like cause
he never suit that side to me when I was
younger just the trail from him is
unbelievable
what for you would mean justice for
Becky him did frame in a room of
laorfamily and watch weapons